when you think of a war reporter who do
you
picture someone like
this or someone like
this maybe
him or maybe someone like
this
her
I'm asked all the time what does it feel
like to be one of the only women working
in your field how do you cope in such a
male dominated industry as Frontline War
reporting the question continues to
baffle me women have been doing this
work for over a
century from Martha ghorn to Clare
hollingwood from Margarita Higgins to
Christian
amanor in fact one of the the reasons I
wanted to become a foreign correspondent
and a war reporter was watching these
women in the field
reporting they were professional Role
Models every evening at 6: p.m. on the
news when I was a little girl in my
living room growing up in Northern
Ireland women reporting from all over
the world on the
BBC and the men were listening to
them
today when I go to war zones very often
it is a majority of women who are
actually reporting
there so when I point out that I'm no
Trailblazer the next question to come is
why why are so many women becoming War
reporters my answer to this question is
quick and easy because we are really
really good at it
so good in fact that war reporting today
the very nature of reporting and
therefore how Wars are perceived by
those we report to has been changed by
women taking the lead the types of
stories that are covered the angles that
are taken have been shaped by the fact
that more and more women are reporting
them
the debate over whether or not men and
women are different in the workplace
whether that we should highlight these
differences whether it matters has gone
on for years in war reporting it hasn't
always been a given that we should lean
into our gender
lens for years women who have fought to
be at the front line to be given
assignments in major Wars Often by male
editors have felt the pressure not to be
pigeonholed into covering women's issues
or softer
topics who here hasn't felt this way if
you've ever been one of the first women
in a male-dominated field that pressure
to be one of the guys to not be too
emotional I was first struck by the
number of female War reporters when
covering the war in Syria it was one of
my first ever major assignments for a TV
News Network I was to be smuggled across
the border from Lebanon into a rebel
stronghold in early
2012 the activists who were smuggling
journalists in typically took us one at
a time the journalist who preceded me
was a female correspondent for elpis
newspaper in Spain two journalists came
after me together one of them a female
correspondent for CNN the other a female
correspondent for the times of London
called Marie
culvin cvin wouldn't make it out of
Syria alive she was killed by the Assad
forces while reporting on their war
crimes yes this is dangerous
work when I moved to Beirut in 2014 the
war in Syria raged on and the Lebanese
Capital had become a hub for
international journalists who were
living there un covering the war across
the border I was struck by how many of
them were women more obviously of course
those who were on camera TV reporters
but a huge amount in many cases the
majority of print reporters as well were
women walk into any bar and Beirut back
then frequented by International and
Lebanese journalists and you had been
faced with a small crowd of smiling
waving female foreign correspondents
catching up between assignments and
deadlines now while there was plenty of
camaraderie on the assignment in Syria
the war in Afghanistan and recent years
has felt
different the US press as the war came
to an end was less interested in that
conflict beyond what it meant for the
geopolitics in the region or US foreign
affairs and National
Security the few times that I did bump
into female journalists there the few
times I bumped into any journalists
there they were almost always
women one day about 6 months before
Cabell fell to the Taliban I went out to
visit a checkpoint on the outskirts of
Cabell at the time there was already
concern about whether or not the Afghan
forces could hold off a Taliban attack
on the
capital shortly after I arrived another
crew came and the soldiers got very
excited this was a news team from too TV
and the correspondent was one of the
most famous journalists in
Afghanistan her name was Ana Shahed the
soldiers crowded around trying to get a
photograph with her and a
selfie so did
I this sort of thing happened all the
time in Afghanistan women bumping into
one another reporting on that war
between us we covered civilian
casualties women's rights access to
education and the hopes and dreams
Afghans had for their future of course
we also covered the major news of the
day the politics the Frontline fighting
and the conditions for the Afghan
Security Forces but we relentlessly
interviewed civilians profiling doctors
and teachers and business people many of
them women elevating civilian
voices in the early days of the war in
Afghanistan while vital risky and
important work was being done very often
the kind of images that were making it
out of the conflict looked largely like
this as the war came to an end in in its
final years the predominant images were
increasingly looking like
this now of course Afghanistan had
evolved and changed but so too had those
who were carrying the lens through which
the world would see
it now none of this is to negate the
vital and important work our male
colleagues do in the field male
journalists have been and continue to do
brilliant
reporting but what I want to draw
attention to is the rapid growth of
female journalists in the field and also
the impact they've had on the reporting
itself that has come out of War zones
around the
world
now when Wars break out it's humanizing
images like this that are predominantly
broadcast around the world that show how
families and communities are impacted by
War they're no longer the exception they
are the
norm When Vladimir Putin invaded Ukraine
in February 2022 the images that were
broadcast around the world were of
families saying goodbye to fathers and
ke train station children clutching
their pets in in underground bunkers and
the elderly clamoring over Broken
Bridges trying to escape it was these
human images that connected millions of
people to what it was really like there
for people to live through that
war many of the stories coming from the
war in Ukraine were reported by women
earlier this year the Ukraine reporting
team for the washhington post was
awarded an award for courage in
journalism for its huge female Le teams
of editors writers photographers and
journalists and who could forget the
women of Iran who not only are
protesting against the repressive edicts
of their government but leading the
fight to make sure the world covers
their
story every day women act activists and
journalists in Iran fight to make sure
and risk their lives to make sure the
images and videos of their struggle
their protests and the Crackdown against
them make it out it's those voices that
I remember most filling my apartment in
New York City in the middle of the night
for journalists like me and many others
who cannot access the country we have
been able to make contact with these
women they use slow internet connection
and outlawed
vpns now if you're going to report from
a war zone female camaraderie does help
too when Cabell fell to the Taliban in
August 2021 I was part of a small group
of international journalists who decided
to stay at the airport and continue on
there reporting on the evacuations part
of that group included a female producer
for British TV as well as a female
correspondent for Danish television
between the three of us we shared
everything from a precious clean shirt
to eyeliner and hair
brushes we may have been reporting from
a war zone but we all knew the pressures
of being a woman who had to be on TV
that
night and I know what a lot of people
wonder what about the tough
stuff what about the sleeping in
trenches lugging gear coming Under Fire
and the generally rough living
conditions I get asked all the time how
do you take a shower my male colleagues
never get
asked it seems absurd that we have to
keep answering these
questions but again and again women have
proven that they are just as tough Brave
and stoic when faced with the physical
and emotional challenges of reporting
from war zones as the men
why wouldn't we be we've been doing it
for decades since the Spanish Civil War
World War II and the war in Vietnam even
though women at the time were a tiny
minority since those who came before us
nudged the door open just
enough the number of women who have been
able to in the last 20 years get
assigned stories as editors
photographers writers and broadcast
Casters in major war zones has massively
increased we've not only increased in
numbers but crucially we've increased in
our confidence to tell stories that
harnesses are unique perspective on our
own unique
strengths now many of the things we may
have feared in the past would be held
against us our compassion our empathy
and our focus on civilian lives have
become our greatest
strengths we're also seeing that
reflected in our male colleagues
reporting as
well a focus on how War impacts
communities and families more broadly
has become the
gnome we are not just good at this job
because we are empathetic and and softer
and have a really good eye for a human
story we're good at this reporting
because we're soft and empathetic and
strong and tough and
brave we have extraordinary
range and it is female range that is
added to the range of voices and stories
and faces that are making it out and in
front of the public from war zones today
when the world is presented to you not
just in television and radio and print
and magazine by a male gaze but by a
female reporter as well our attitudes to
the outside world change
too we feel more
connected we can see beyond the
statistics the politics and just the war
fighting
we as journalists are at heart
communicators and it is female reporting
that is helping the world better
commune thank
[Applause]
[Music]
you